une toute petite planche de bois c'est
le chemin que 10000 personnes empruntent
depuis cinq jours pour quitter irvine
leur ville bombardée le pont de béton a
été détruit délibérément par les forces
du chrétienne pour ralentir l'arrivée
des russes
tous les moyens sont bons pour fuir les
blessés pourront aussi la route malgré
le manque de transport adapté
et tous ceux qui entament la marche le
fond péril de leur vie alors que les
bombardements se poursuivent joe torre
la bombe il
était né
dans les négociations pour arriver à
établir des corridors humanitaires
permettent de sortir des civils des
zones de combat et de faire entrer
l'aide humanitaire sont complexes il ya
aussi beaucoup de détails de paramètres
qui doivent être mises en place les airs
les lieux les itinéraires d'évacuation
lors des personnes et aussi comment
l'aide peut être acheminée donc les
détails logistiques sont essentielles et
surtout les deux parties opposées
doivent s'entendre sur les conditions
pour établir les corridors ce qui est
loin d'être le cas
un cessez le feu nécessaire pour
commencer l'évacuation n'a pas été
respecté la semaine dernière à marie
gopaul et l'ukraine refuse les corridors
proposé par la russie qui amènerait les
civils vers leur territoire ou celui du
bélarus la russie dicte les corridors
humanitaires
invite la population du crime yen à
venir sur son territoire on peut
imaginer à quel point ça peut servir la
propagande du président poutine de
démontrer à la population russe que les
ukrainiens veulent venir en russie ce
qui évidemment polka dans l'est du pays
les combats se poursuivent et n'épargne
pas les quartiers résidentiels comme ici
à kharkhiv où les résidents se sont
réveillés lundi matin devant une scène
de désolation les maisons et des
immeubles résidentiels réduits à des
décombres dans son esprit cette
diminution des droits
des civils victimes de la guerre se
présente à l'hôpital pour soigner leurs
blessures et pour partager leurs
expériences des derniers jours dans la
deuxième plus grande ville d'ukraine
pendant que se négocie malheureusement
les bombardements continus on est face à
des massacres historique c'est une très
grande tristesse mais il faut évidemment
espérer que les la désescalade
surviennent le plus rapidement possible
petite lueur d'espoir peut-être qu'ils
avaient steam que le troisième cycle de
négociations russo ukrainiennes qui
s'est conclue en fin de journée commence
à donner des résultats pour
l'établissement d'un corridor
humanitaire
du côté russe on estime que des
corridors pourrait voir le jour dès
demain reste à voir
cybèle devoir humanitaire de protéger
des civils prendra le dessus sur les
combats ici pascal harrison juliet radio
canada montréal